three people just attacked a hostess at
a very famous italian restaurant in new
york on the upper west side because the
hostess asked to see their vaccine cards
asked for proof of vaccination i don't
think the restaurant wanted to do this
i've been to this restaurant on a number
of occasions and i think they're good
good old restaurant carmines but the
city is forcing them to and so the
hostess was complying with the stupid
city ordinance
and these three people
beat up the hostess
now
if you watch cnn if you read the new
york times you know
who were these three people they were
three
white
male republican probably christian trump
supporters
anti-vaxxer
murderers
who wouldn't
show the vaccine proof so they don't get
their bowl of spaghetti right
so what are their names
uh keita
nikingay
rankin 44 years old
tyani kishay rankin 21
and sally rochelle lewis 49.
they were arrested and charged with
assaulting criminal mischief they don't
so those
names gosh i don't want to get in
trouble i don't want to stereotype or
they don't
they sound a little more ethnically
ambiguous than we were told about the
unveil the white male trump supporters
right
they don't sound male that's for sure
no it turns out there are three tourists
three black women who were visiting
new york
they show up to the restaurant they
don't want to go along with the mandate
i think these women are from texas where
you don't need to show proof of your
fouchiauchi so they must have been very
surprised did you know that 80
of the grass-fed beef sold in the united
states is actually imported from
overseas sometimes they'll say it's from
a local farm it's from a local farm in
south america somewhere it's not from
one here which is why you got to check
out the good ranchers the good ranchers
are helping out the american rancher
they're helping out the american
consumer and they are giving you top
quality beef for unbelievable prices so
whatever you want they have they have
actually more than beef they've got
better than organic chicken but me i'm a
little more of a beef guy they got the
t-bones they got the fillets they got
the strips they have
to my mind basically the best burgers
out there they're gourmet delicious
burgers that are juicy that i've had
within the past few weeks go check them
out right now
you get steakhouse quality at a price
every family can afford right now if you
go to
goodranchers.com you can save 20 bucks
or better yet you can subscribe and save
on each box of mouth-watering american
meats that will show up right on
schedule to your door so right now 20
bucks off free express shipping if you
go to goodranchers.com knowles or use
code knowles at checkout 20 bucks off in
free express shipping at
goodranchers.com
knowles
now a lawyer for the women this is where
the story gets complicated
now a story a lawyer for the women is
saying that the hostess used a racial
slur i don't believe that i've been to
carmine's i just don't think that's true
there's so many hoaxes that go on i
write about a lot of those hoaxes race
hoaxes in
my book speechless which you can get the
the worst thing you can be called in
america is is a racist the worst offense
you can possibly commit is to utter the
n-word and so the the lawyer is saying
that i don't think there's any evidence
that the restaurant is vigorously
denying that now blm is showing up and
saying they're going to protest not just
car mines for the hostess's alleged
behavior that i am fairly certain did
not take place
but they're also going to protest the
city's vaccine mandate which they say is
is a way to keep black people out of
places
because
contrary to cnn reports
black people disproportionately are not
getting the vaccine and so they want to
blame everything on white males because
white males are the
worst creatures in the history of the
world and everything they do is terrible
but they because they're trying to blame
this they're trying to discourage this
behavior
they
they don't want to acknowledge that a
lot of black people are engaging the
same kind of behavior namely not wanting
to get the pouchy algae right away so
this is a very politically this might be
the most complex political story of all
time because the first part of the story
three women refused to go along with a
vaccine mandate love that love that
refused to show their papers at the
restaurant love that man that's great
kudos to them next part of the story
they beat up the hostess well that's bad
we don't like that don't beat up the
hostess okay especially at carmine's
because it's a nice restaurant
hate that next part of the story they're
accusing this hostess now of using a
racial slur almost certainly didn't
happen really hate that that's ugly
that's ugly racial politics
fourth part of the story blm shows up
now i really hate that because they're
going to go loot all the all the
spaghetti you know just like the blm
arsonists and terrorists looted city
after city and burned down police
buildings and courthouses really hate
that
but then the final part of the story
blm is opposing
the mask mandate
city-wide
i like that am i on the side of blm now
i guess in this regard i sort of am
politics makes for strange bedfellows
this to me is the most interesting part
of this whole story it's the it's the
only reason why this is news as far as
i'm concerned it's not because of the
typical racial politics that you always
hear about it's not that to me is the
least interesting part of the story
what's interesting here
is not the race aspect it's the kovit
aspect
this kovid
kovidistan this new kovidistan country
that we're all living in
is
realigning a lot of politics at least
temporarily and maybe it'll have more of
a permanent effect
the people who are opposed to the covid
public health dictatorship are not just
white male trump supporters
they're
black young black women
but we were told that's not possible
the people who are opposed to the mask
mandates
are
some radical leftists actually too
the people who do not like the way that
our government is being run
it's not it doesn't break down just on
party lines or even ideological lines
it's a little bit more
us versus them it's a little bit more
the people versus the ruling class it's
a little bit more the people who thought
we were living in a constitutional
republic versus
increasingly the oligarchy would you
know an oligarchy if you saw one
and so everyone when they're talking
about this carmine story and it's it is
going to crop up on tv you're only going
to hear people talking about the racial
aspect
don't take the bait don't fall for that
the interesting aspect
is what impelled these women
to
lose their temper and you know start you
know punching people in the first place
and what then impelled the racial
politics because that's the only way you
can talk about it because you're not
allowed to talk about the public health
dictatorship i'm so glad you enjoyed
that clip if you like that oh baby the
best is yet to come you gotta check out
the whole episode you can get that here
on youtube and you can comment and
subscribe you can also get it at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
head on over there type in the michael
knowles show subscribe
you will never miss an episode i would
greatly appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]